the final episode of Liv and Maddie
aired all the way back in 2017 but we
are still discovering secrets about the
Disney Channel show so you know how I
play both Liv and Maddie we've got 10
behind-the-scenes secrets from this twin
tastic series keep watching to find out
which secret dove Cameron managed to
hide from producers until her very last
day on set the entire premise of Liv and
Maddie is about two twin sisters
reconnecting and learning to live
together again but would you believe
that they were never supposed to be
twins in the show the entire concept for
Liv and Maddie was completely different
at first dove Cameron was actually cast
in a different role and she was only
supposed to play one character
originally the series was supposed to be
more about a blended family it was
intended to be a show similar to the
Brady Bunch or step by step but for a
new generation ultimately Disney decided
to take a new direction blended family
shows are always popular so they wanted
to be innovative but if it wasn't about
the twin sisters Liv and Maddie what was
it going to be called the original title
was bits and pieces we're glad that they
went the direction they did Liv and
Maddie was a fresh take there had never
been a show where twins were separated
for a few years and then reunited and
forced to get along as teens this unique
concept kept the show feeling new for
all four seasons it's sort of like one
direction but for old ladies like most
Disney Channel shows Liv and Maddie
episodes usually ran for around 25
minutes but it took a lot longer to film
one episode in fact at the beginning of
the series one episode took a full week
to shoot but soon they got it down to an
hour a typical Liv and Maddie episode
took two full days to film every single
thing that I do in my career going
forward will be in reference to this
show a lot goes into filming any show
they had to do multiple takes of each
shot to get it right actors might forget
their lines there are set changes that
had to get set up
everyone needed to change costumes and
get their hair and makeup touched up but
one of the main reasons it took so long
was because dove Cameron played two
characters she had to shoot each scene
that had Liv and Maddie in it twice
additionally it wasn't easy to switch
characters
it took Dov two whole hours to swap
looks imagine the days that she had to
do that more than once that had to be
exhausting be hard because you know you
wake up before there's really time to do
anything else and then when you get home
you want to go straight to sleep a
Disney Channel set is always an exciting
place but one day in particular was
extra exciting for the cast of Liv and
Maddie one little known fact is that a
super secret wedding took place it was
so secret that even the bride didn't
know what was going on Betsy Sullinger
was an executive producer of Liv and
Maddie being a TV producer is a pretty
demanding job but she loves it
however she couldn't get work off for
her 25th wedding anniversary so her
husband chambers Stephens took things
into his own hands
he plotted with their friends on and off
the set to surprise her with a second
wedding chambers and their son Twain
sneaked on set
Betsy thought that they were filming
something for the gag reel she was so
shocked when she came on set and saw her
husband two friends posed as bridesmaids
and clipped a veil on her hair
then the director Andy fickman performed
a very short very funny vow renewal
Service Chambers did such a good job he
even matched to what his wife was
wearing that day but after the wedding
it was back to business as usual
there's no doubt that dove Cameron is a
great actor and her time on Liv and
Maddie proves it she was so believable
as two different characters some people
thought that the show starred an actual
set of twins Dov did such a great job at
playing both roles that even her fellow
cast mates got confused there were times
that the cast and crew worked sure
whether she was being Liv Maddie or Dov
it has to be weird to have multiple
personas and a we can only imagine how
confusing it would be for everybody else
however Dov always knew exactly which
role she was in she had some sneaky
little tricks to help her stay in the
correct character stay tuned to find out
what they were we're gonna do it any
good elf would do and go out there and
we take presents away from children
here's a popular question if Maddie and
live or two people and Dov is only one
person how on earth did they film more
often than not Liv and Maddie were on
set together they had whole
conversations in every episode
it just took a little cinematic magic to
make it happen when the show first aired
Disney gave Dov an option they could use
green screens and have someone hold up a
mask when she needed to interact with
the other twin they also said that there
could be nothing there and they could
record her voice for the other lines but
Dov insisted on having body doubles to
get the feel of each character she
needed to look in someone's eyes Emmy
Buckner and Shelby Wolfert were her body
doubles throughout the show the body
doubles were also useful when they
needed to film Liv and Maddie close
together if you saw the back of one of
the Twins heads
it was probably their double but when we
needed to see both Twins faces some
fancy cinematography came into play
there was a stationary camera instead of
a moving one so the screens were the
same the actor stayed on different sides
of the set and couldn't cross invisible
lines dove Cameron would say her lines
switch roles and film it all over again
but this time she would be on the other
side of the set these shots were merged
to impose
production movie magic is one of the
best parts of show business with a
camera a computer and a few tricks TV
shows can pull off some impressive
illusions sometimes these things are
advanced to CGI other times it's simply
a realistic set that's exactly the case
in Liv and Maddie there were plenty of
scenes in the show that were filmed
outside including several in the
family's backyard but most of these
scenes weren't a shot outdoors the
backyard was just another set inside of
the studio we were shocked when we
learned that the studio wasn't real but
it's a lot easier to keep everything on
the show contained in one studio plus
they didn't have to worry about the
weather they could shoot a sunny scene
even if it was storming outside we
wonder if any of the scenes outside of
the main set were real what secret
tidbit of information - dove Cameron
hide from everyone on set keep watching
to find out I took basketball very
seriously so we loved the costumes from
Liv and Maddie after she came from
Hollywood Liv had a quirky vibrant style
dov described it as Barbie meets 3rd
grader but somehow she managed to pull
it off
dov even got to wear not one but two
awesome wardrobes on the show it was one
of her favorite parts she loved watching
Maddie style evolve just remember all
you gotta do is wear it the way that you
want we're early on Maddie wears really
simple plain clothes but as she grows as
a character her style shifts into
something more mature and daring not
only were there double costumes but
there were double wigs as well Liv and
Maddie had different wigs that match to
dubs hair why didn't her hair just get
styled differently each time the Dove
has said it was an important part of
switching characters in her mind she was
able to get into character when the new
wig went on in upcycling there are no
rules
you get to take whatever you want and
make it your own it can be hard to grow
up in the public eye especially as a
Disney Channel star Disney wants its
young stars to have a certain persona on
and off camera
dov opened up to Teen Vogue about these
challenges when the show was in its
final season dove is a naturally
positive person but apparently people
would accuse her of being fake that was
hurtful but she didn't stop from being
herself can sometimes be really
overwhelming for me getting photographs
is it causes anxiety people thought that
because she played goofy blonde
characters she was unintelligent that
couldn't be further from the truth
but dub says that she has to work at
being happy and it's not always easy in
2017
she was excited about branching out she
said she hopes to play some edgy earth
characters because she's naturally drawn
to them we've also seen her blossom as a
musician since she left Disney Channel
live and Maddie was important to her and
she considers the cast to be her family
but we're excited to see where she goes
in the future when Disney Channel
launches a new show it's pretty much
guaranteed that it won't have more than
three seasons only a handful of shows
have ever gotten a fourth season
the first was That's So Raven others
include Wizards of Waverly Place and
Hannah Montana
so when Liv and Maddie was renewed for a
fourth season it was a huge deal they
became the seventh show to ever have a
fourth season it also became the only
four season show to lose a major cast
member in the final season you are still
in huge trouble we're on board
Benjamin King who played their dad only
appeared a few times in season four his
character stayed in Wisconsin for a
coaching job while the rest of the
family went to California whenever major
characters have left Disney series
before they were never renewed for a
fourth season but Liv and Maddie was
still a hit
even without Benjamin as a regular if
you're signing up for a sports team
when dum found out she was playing twins
she knew she needed to play each
character differently she took this down
to the tiniest detail and she kept it a
secret until the show wrapped dove may
live left-handed while Matty was
right-handed did she do it just to see
if anyone noticed did it help her switch
the characters in her mind we aren't
sure but it sure was clever you don't
think we accidentally wrapped it do you
when filming ended she dropped the big
secret to the showrunners they were all
shocked they went straight to the
editing room to see if she was telling
the truth as many times as they had seen
the footage they had never noticed they
talked to the props department to all of
the notebooks had different handwriting
depending on whether it was lives or
Maddie's that just shows how dedicated
dove is as an actor she's also very
sneaky are you more of a live or a Maddy
let us know in the comments section
thanks for watching be sure to LIKE and
subscribe we'll see you next time on the
things
[Music]